Game of the Year is upon us a time of
which we come together as one loving
family to rejoice a year in games and
like all functioning families we do so
in a civilized and embracing matter but
some of you may be asking how does
GameSpot decide such a prestigious award
for one gaming year that is with the
exception of 1998 to 2001 where
rearwards
to a year one to a console game went to
a PC game times have changed anyway some
others believe we just pick it from a
hat well I can assure you that isn't
entirely true in the 23 years that
GameSpot's awarding this award a lot has
changed in terms of process style and
presentation so here's how we do it hey
John that looks really good
names Davi everyone in the office amidst
their top 10 games of 2019 number one
gets 10 points number 2 gets 9 points
and so on
here's mr. game of the year thanks kid
now we get into deliberations the votes
aren't the deciding factor but they help
us nominate 10 games for the game of the
year Jon whiteboard it's David yeah
whatever
anyways then we share those results with
the wonderful audience on December 10th
and then we wrap up on December 16th
once all the nominations are announced
we will be revealing game spots game of
the year on December 17
[Music]
also this year we're bringing back
editor spotlight Awards there's a lot of
exceptional games that came out this
year we want to make sure we highlight
all of them the editor spotlight lets
staff give a little extra attention to
games that may not have made the cut
like Ice Age scratch snow the adventure
we will also have platform categories
than any particular order best games
subscription service best mobile games
best evolving multiplayer lifestyle game
best expansion or DLC best ps4 games
best switch games best PC games best
Xbox games best VR games best reissues
and best bathroom which rightfully goes
to death stranding we hope this gives
you a very transparent view in how we
tackle this very important award in the
meantime regardless of whether or not
the game you think wins let's just at
least agree on that video games are cool
and stuff excuse me sir would you like
to pick the game of the year oh sure why
not huh look at that Shenmue 3
[Music]
[Music]